I routinely point out that we could
eliminate 80% of all chronic disease by
using what we know.
And we don't do that.
We really bogged down in bickering about
do we know what we know and,
and is this part of what we know more
important than that part of what we know
and in no place is that a bigger problem
than diet.
There's obviously a lot of money to be
made from confusion.
Uh,
some years ago I worked on air for Good
Morning America and I saw firsthand that
there really is invested interest in tv
and the median propagating constant
change.
If you say the same thing about diet on
air,
enough times in a row,
people lose interest in your dietary
segments.
If you say something different every
time,
it's always interesting to an end
tomorrow for a new answer.
So the media are in on it.
The fad diet authors are in on it.
Uh,
basically a lot of people who just think
that their view of the truth through a
particular tunnel is the only truth are
in on it.
But the result is we squander the
opportunity to use what we know because
we bogged down in debate about what we
don't know quite so well.
So having completely lost my patients
for the status quo decided to do
something about this.
And,
and it's really challenging now because
there was a time not all that long ago
when a single voice could rise above the
den.
For example about doctor coop when he
was surgeon general or Benjamin spock
and the influence that he had on parents
raising young children.
But that era is gone because we live in
the age of the blogosphere in cyberspace
and everybody's got a microphone and,
and there's just this incredible amount
of static.
And at the end of it all the answer to
the question,
can we say what diet is best for health?
And by health we mean longevity,
vitality,
weight control,
all the good stuff that we all want.
The answer is absolutely no.
If what we mean is a very specific
prescriptive,
my diet can beat your diet.
So,
you know,
can we say whether the best
Mediterranean diet is better than the
best Vegan Diet?
Or if that's better than the best Palio
Diet for human health?
The answer is no.
If what we mean though by can we say
what diet is best for health is a basic
theme of optimal living.
Then the answer is a categorical yes.
It's incredibly clear from incredibly
voluminous,
incredibly consistent literature all
around the world.
Diverse populations,
diverse methods,
observational epidemiology where you
just watch and see what happens.
Intervention trials where you assigned
people to die.
It's randomized control trials and real
world experience with large populations
like the blue zones and frankly Michael
Paul and pretty much nailed this one.
Eat Food not too much,
mostly plants that really captures the
essence of all the world's diets that
are associated with good health
outcomes.
And when I wrote about this with my
colleague Frank Hugh from Harvard,
we said wholesome foods in sensible
combinations,
and then to put a little meat on the
bones is it were wholesome foods means
vegetables,
fruits,
whole grains,
beans,
lentils,
nuts,
seeds,
whether without everything else you want
to eat.
Fish,
eat fish.
You won't eat seafood.
He'd seafood.
You want to eat some lean meat?
Do you want to eat eggs?
Do you want to eat dairy?
Do,
but the bulk of your diet should be
vegetables,
fruits,
whole grains,
beans,
lentils,
nuts and seeds.
This is true all around the world where
people do the best.
It's true in the Mediterranean where the
diets or high fat,
but the fat is coming from nuts,
seeds,
olives,
avocado,
olive oil.
It's true in the Far East where the
diets are low fat because there's lots
of vegetables,
grains,
and less of the nuts and the avocado.
And frankly it's true of diets as
diverse as Vegan and Paleo people who
really know what they're doing with the
palio diet are eating a wide variety of
plants,
preferably wild plants,
but not necessarily and lean meat,
preferably game.
So it's real food,
not too much.
And it is mostly plants.
And a Vegan diet is a slightly wider
variety of plant foods without the meat,
but they're actually more alike than
different.
So there really is incredible clarity
about the fundamentals of healthy
eating.
And I think really the big issue for all
of us is focusing our efforts on making
the fundamentals of that.
Dietary pattern more accessible in our
culture and allowing for people to
choose the variant on that theme that
works best for them.
So you need to eat well.
Even in a world that keeps running on
Dunkin,
you need to eat well and feed your
children well in a world that market's
multicolored marshmallows as part of a
complete breakfast,
you need to be physically active in a
world that gives you no time for
exercise and gives you more and more
technology to do everything that muscles
used to do.
So the theme of healthy eating,
unbelievably clear,
this specific claims about my diet can
beat your diet,
all false,
all somebody trying to sell you
something,
step away from your credit card and
nobody will get hurt.
Okay.